[Musique]
blake
choisissez un homme prenez votre
paquetage j'espérais que ce sera une
bonne journée
l'espoir c'est dangereux
vous avez un frère au 2e bataillon du
mans général ils vont tomber dans un
piège
vous avez ordres de leur remettre un
message annulant l'assaut de demain
matin
si vous échouez ce sera un massacre
si on en parlait deux minutes pourquoi
on à l'ordre de traverser ici là c'est
le front allemand si on s'y prend mal
personne n'arrivera à rejoindre ton
frère
six mois
ça ne peut se terminer que d'une seule
façon
aux derniers survivants
[Musique]
il faut continuer hier
parviendrez jamais comme ça cap aura
peut-être sa grille
[Musique]
si vous n'arrivez pas à temps
nous perdrons 1600 hommes dont votre
frère bonne chance
non